- Hi, my name is Grace Hwang,
and I'm a School Programs
Educator here at MoMA.
This piece by Jackson Pollock is
one of my favorite pieces to teach,
just because of its sheer size and scale.
And it just kind of takes up
the whole wall and the whole room,
and I love to think about it as a thought
that kind of takes up the
whole space of your mind.
It's kind of subversive, the reason
why I like teaching from this object.
because it really
confronts students' ideas
about skill and creating art.
Sometimes students will say,
when they look at this
painting for the first time,
that the artist must have
been angry or he's depressed,
and what's interesting is to
facilitate that idea of anger.
Well, what movements do
you make when you're angry?
These kind of violent movements,
these very strong movements
and quick movements,
and to compare that with
a very opposite emotion
of like excitement, and
when you're really excited
about something, you're
just as moving very quickly.
It's interesting to think of this painting
as the collection of lines of energy,
and you begin to follow
as you look at One,
maybe some moments that look
sort of like electricity
and kind of staticky,
and then some movements that
are moving very quickly,
the very thin movements
moving very quickly,
and then some of these pools of paint,
kind of these pauses and these lulls.
A lot of times I have
students think about,
you know, well, give me your first word
guttural reaction to this piece,
and a lot of times
they'll say things like,
"Crazy, chaos, random!"
And sometimes, you know,
after a conversation
about things that are controlled chaos
or things that are seemingly
random and out of control,
it's really interesting that towards
the end of the conversation,
it might go more towards
thoughts about the universe being
controlled chaos, or the cosmos.
A lot of times conversations can get
really out there and very philosophical,
and I think it's kind of a
magic moment when that happens.